we finally got our first in-depth look
at tears of the Kingdom's gameplay and
there were a ton of new details to pick
apart but as a combat expert in breath
of the wild I'm going to focus
specifically on Link's new battling
abilities both intangible information
and on theorizing possibilities you may
have missed if you enjoy in-depth
breakdowns like this let us know by
liking this video
the combat Porsche starts around when
link approaches this tree branch lighter
in color to match these lighter colored
trees in these Sky biomes in this game
like the previous game it's highly
likely to have two attack power this is
also when link is approached by a new
enemy called a soldier construct which
is also wielding an identical tree
branch it goes on the offensive and
attacks link but gets staggered
immediately this is already decent
information because it can show us some
early damage numbers in this part of the
game without directly telling us without
going too in depth on how blocky types
are calculated all enemies have a base
attack then that's added to the weapon's
additional attack if your enemy's output
is higher than your Shield it will
continue to attack without stagger
so in this example this shows that this
Shield must at Absolute minimum have
more than two defense power
[Music]
for continuity's sake of canonical
equipment it's safe to say that this
Shield probably mirrors the stats of
breath of the wild starting equipment
the Traveler's Shield which has four
Shield strength in a clip later on a
construct attacks link with a wooden
stick that has four attack and hits
Link's mushroom-equipped Shield without
staggering so this could mean that
constructs have a base attack of one
added to the wooden clubs for damage to
overcome Link's Shield without being
staggered side note with this clip we
have yet to see a sneak strike chaining
is still a thing the ability to chain
multiple sneak attacks over and over by
wrapping around to the other side
because his construct was taken out with
one shot it was hard to tell but this
mechanic might return
Now link flips to the offensive and we
can clearly calculate damage from here
the standard Branch combo does 2 damage
per swing with the final swing breaking
for a critical hit leading to double
damage these critical strikes can also
disarm enemies which link then quickly
steals the enemy's Branch this causes
the car stroke to get angry which is the
same mechanic in breath of the Wild's
enemies
[Music]
then with another three strikes for a
total of 16 damage you could take out
the soldier construct link then picks up
his materials which includes a soldier
construct's horn which we'll see again
later in the video this part is likely
to become many players favorite edition
the fusibility from the looks of it this
ability Auto targets close materials and
gives you the option to fuse it with
your weapon or your Shield this seems to
reset or more likely just add additional
durability to the weapon you currently
have which after many players complaints
about weapon durability is likely to be
a welcome change if you look closely
there are small numbers you can see to
show the damage changes as well with the
plus 2 indicator and a small outline of
4 next to it meaning the two attack
power Branch gains an additional 2
attack with the boulder resulting in a
weapon of 4 attack power total as a side
note the developers have a similar setup
here as to the great Plateau with
Boulders precariously placed above
enemies to give you the option to push
them onto unsuspecting enemies below
LinkedIn instead approaches the
constructs head on since they have 16 HP
and you have a 4 attack power weapon it
only takes 4 hits to take them down at
this point you're probably starting to
think about the possibilities you can
make with multiple weapons and materials
getting stuck together along with many
many questions such as what would happen
if you fuse two almost broken weapons
together does it reset the durability or
add them together we still haven't seen
fused weapons break yet so does the tip
portion break separately can the handle
portion break as you drop the tipped
half can you unfuse weapons back apart
like you did with this raft does fusing
onto an already fused weapon replace the
modification or add to it because there
was an option to do that here but our
Numa passed that up when he attached The
Rock to the shield instead can you fuse
together magical wants I'm sure you can
attach a flame blade onto a stick but
what happens on the other way around or
a metal weapon onto a thunderblade can
we fuse ingredients onto weapons as well
as Shields how do these all work with
boomerangs does it affect the
boomerang's ability to fly or it's
attacking width while Alice mechanic has
huge possibilities it leaves us with
many questions that I'm sure the
developers have worked hard to figure
out over the past six years finally
let's talk about bow and arrow gameplay
one thing that sticks out to me
immediately is the quick menu system in
breath of the wild the d-pad normally
shows Shields runes and weapons and when
you draw a bow the d-pad quick menu
shifts to arrows runes and Bows this
time in tears of the Kingdom it's now
Shields materials and weapons and when a
bow is equipped only the bow quick menu
is affected this means that either a
Elemental arrows are out of the picture
entirely and are replaced by attachable
choo choo jellies or B Elemental arrows
are still an option but are instead
considered a material you get later on
the quick menu pulled up here only shows
a few materials but still shows quite a
bit the soldiers construct horn we
picked up earlier is attachable and now
the Amber material has taken a new shape
as an arrowhead it's safe to say that
all the gems in the game are like this
now and I'm guessing Diamond tipped
arrowheads are a thing that may pack a
punch one theory is that that these gems
will do as much additional damage as
they sell for rupees which could play
into a nice gamble of push and pull with
your wallet versus your damage or could
go back to how they originally planned
to use these gems as Elemental
arrowheads since they used to have
elemental properties early in breath of
the Wild's development he then switches
over to a korok frond not to be confused
with the korok leaf because this korok
material is considered a healing item
then he switches back over to the white
choo choo jelly to simulate an ice arrow
white Jelly's freezing explosions do 10
damage normally so a combination of this
Bose strength and the supposed bonus
damage you receive when equipping these
materials kills the 16 HP enemy
immediately the closest we ever got to
something like this in breath of the
wild was using korok leaves and balloons
stasis
or using item drop glitches to throw
them a certain distance
directly attaching these effects to
arrows opens up a whole new layer of
combat that was much harder to access
before we then get a second look at the
key's eyeball attachment from a previous
trailer which automatically homes in on
enemies this is definitely most useful
when performing non-bullet time combat
when it's difficult to aim quickly in
real time it's still difficult to know
how this mechanic works if it
prioritizes Wildlife or enemies first or
whatever just comes into its range
before either way this gives Keys much
higher value to hunt down and farm
finally I want to briefly touch upon
Ultra hand at first glance yes this is a
crafting ability not designed for combat
but players who have played the game
long enough know that this kind of
ability can come in clutch when tied
with breath of the Wild's amazing engine
to drop objects onto enemies the fact
that this ability is not tied to only
magnetic objects anymore opens up a lot
of opportunities to use more of the
environment as your personal bat
especially when paired together with the
motion control option which can lead to
nauseous but high damage situations
while we saw the basics of combat here
they still haven't shown their hand in
any trailers of the Advanced Techniques
with any slowdown abilities such as
parrying flurry rushes or bullet time
but something tells me they have
something up their sleeve we'll see soon
enough
hopefully you enjoyed this breakdown of
what we've seen in the latest Gameplay
trailer when tears of the Kingdom
launches we'll have a host of video
guides and a new series of things you
didn't know so stick around here on
Gamespot
foreign